- When you young, you're not thinking,
and everybody has made a bad choice.
And because you stressed out,
you go change your gender
because you wanna try something new.
Once you do it, you can't go back.
The more you throw stuff at
kids before they developed
that's indoctrination.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] When Jubilee
created middle ground,
the intention was to
uncover humanity and empathy
shared among strangers
with opposing beliefs.
Whether your political beliefs
are on the left or the right
we all exist within our own echo chambers.
So for this episode,
we partnered with Ground
News and created a test
that can analyze your new sources
and show you their biases.
The participants of this
episode agreed to take the quiz
and share the results.
We encourage you to do the same.
- [Interviewer] Step forward
if you agree with the prompt,
cancel culture is a good thing.
- We have the freedom
to say what you want,
but everyone else has the
freedom to respond and cancel you
if you say something that
is racist, homophobic,
transphobic, et cetera,
cancel culture is definitely
good in the means of like
deep platforming people
who are spreading very hateful messages.
- [Interviewer] What is your opinion,
on Trump being canceled on Twitter?
- When you go onto Twitter,
whatever you check the,
I accept the guidelines,
the community guidelines.
I agree to follow them
and he didn't follow them.
So Twitter has the right
to take him off the app.
- And people that might
make the counter argument
that Twitter is bias
will only cancel right wing politicians.
That's not true at all.
Twitter and other forms of
social media have canceled
left wing activists.
There is an equal balance on both sides.
- You brought up
canceling him off Twitter,
I'm sorry I disagree.
When the Taliban can
use ours, social media,
but an ex-president can't.
There is something wrong with that.
- Did the Taliban violate
community get guidelines?
- Doesn't matter.
- I mean, I think it matters to Twitter
what their community guidelines are.
That's why they ban Trump,
'cause Trump violated
community guidelines.
That's what every platform
has, whether it be TikTok,
YouTube, Instagram.
- The Taliban stone people,
because they're gay.
- If they've done that
and they've posted videos
of stoning gay people, I
agree they should be removed.
And that is fundamentally wrong.
- It's the problem is they're
smart enough to not do that.
- Well then why wasn't Trump.
- President wasn't smart
enough to not do that I guess.
- If I'm a American and
I have to vote between
this person, this person,
I need equal access to both of
them to decide what's right.
Bro you could be a clansman.
You could say you hate black people.
That's not my job to police your language.
I can't expect everybody to love me
and extinct the way I think
all y'all think different.
I mean that's totally dope.
But the fact that you
want somebody removed
because they think differently
that could be you one day.
- Do you think freedom of speech
is something that still exists in America?
- We do have aspects of freedom of speech.
Like you can't go into a
movie theater and yell fire.
So obviously there are
limits of freedom speech.
- But they're picking and
choosing who they're silencing
and who they're letting talk.
- If people react
negatively to what you say,
it goes both ways.
You can't just say that oh they can't.
- 100%.
- Oh, okay.
- Absolutely.
- [Interviewer] America is
becoming less and less safe.
- I'll leave this to you guys.
- So I have a lot of friends
that have been in the military
for the last 20 years
because they refused to get vaccinated.
They told me that they would
be dishonorably discharged
or kicked outta the military.
I just believe we're losing
a lot of good service men
with the current situation
that we're in right now.
- A lot of police officers are down.
Crime is up all over
when police aren't there,
we're murdering each other
at a really high rate.
Police are in those neighborhoods
because the homicide rate is high.
Y'all can run around talking
about police all you want.
But I challenge any at these liberal kids
to spend two weeks in the
environment I grew up in
and I promise your
perspective will change.
- The one advantage we
have about being older,
we've been through a threat
or two and our enemies,
like China, the communis party in China,
they're laughing at us.
Russia is like, we don't need to do much
they're gonna screw it up on their own.
We need to get the help
of our younger people
that haven't been through a threat before
to realize a lot of what's
going on is not good.
My name is Mike I'm 59 years old
and I'm a conservative parent.
Growing up during the 1980s
that was a huge influence on me.
And it formed my views and
the people that I was around
that's the reason why I'm
a conservative parent.
I think America should be
more middle of the road
and not be necessarily more liberal.
And if anything should be
a hint more on the conservative side,
because we're gonna watch our freedoms
get distinguished or encroached
if we don't guard those freedoms
and make sure that all
of our children have a chance to succeed.
- [Interviewer] Can the
disagreers step forward?
- I have actually wished I came up here
for the agreeing section because
I think I interpreted
the definite of safety
the same way that you guys did.
But after hearing you guys conversation,
I started thinking about how
our American people aren't safe
in the face of like imminent,
like climate disasters
that are coming our way
and how we don't have the
infrastructure to deal with that.
- I actually very much agree with that,
'cause I think we need to define
like kind of like what we mean
by like we're less safe now.
Do we mean like there was
more homicides after COVID
or like what do we mean?
- I would say before we got
rid of half our military
or half our police
force slavery was legal,
the Holocaust was legal.
So we can look at all
of these mass atrocities
and say we're doing what's right.
Everybody who was a part of
the Holocaust government,
they were doing what Hitler said,
they were doing what was right.
So everybody losing their
job for not getting vacs
and all of the vacs people
you got who can we control?
Everybody who get the shot
that's who gonna do what we say.
The enemies are coming and
we don't care about that
'cause we wanna care about
what color we should wear
and pride and critical race.
There's like no one else cares
about that but us in America,
that's our problem.
- So you think that talking
about sexual orientation
and all that kind of stuff takes away
from the safety of our country.
- Who you sleep with has
no merit in the real world.
What does it matter?
- Okay, let's just broaden the scope
with the coronavirus pandemic
why did it take weeks for us as a country
to mobilize together to fight
the public health crisis
that was already affecting the nation.
- It was a scam to get Donald
to Trump out of office.
It's all fake, it's my opinion.
- I agree with you.
I don't think that we could create,
or the Democrats could create
some international plan
getting all of these
scientific communities
outside of just the U.S.
and even international
governments on their side
for something that they're just trying
to get Trump out of office.
I feel like that's heavily ridiculous.
- Trump was the thorn
and nobody saw coming
and they had to find a way
to get him outta there.
If there's no mail-in voting
100% Trump is the president
president right now, 100%.
- Yeah, because overwhelmingly
mail-in ballots were to Biden
and that's obvious like.
- Exactly.
- That's not because mail-in
ballots are fraudulent.
'Cause mail-in ballots are
actually not fraudulent at all
this election was the safest
election in recorded history.
- There's a lot of videos.
You see people with fake ballots.
So that's here and there I'm not.
- That's just hearsay of
random people on TikTok.
Are we really gonna like take that
as like empirical evidence?
- It's personal opinion.
- My name is Parker I'm
19 and I'm a liberal,
my sisters and I have
become a lot more liberal,
a lot more left leaning over time
while my parents have
stayed a bit conservative.
Before when I was a conservative,
I kind of just went off a
lot of the indoctrination
and propaganda that was
spread to me when I was a kid.
I grew up on the fact that,
oh, we shouldn't have increased taxes
because taxes are just
negatively affecting us.
Personal responsibility isn't
what a lot of the decisions
people make in society is based on
it's mainly based upon their environments.
How they're socialized by their
parents, people around them,
things like that.
- [Interviewer] My new
source is more reliable
than the other sides.
- New source.
- When I look at conservative news,
I see a lot of conspiracies
that I don't necessarily agree with.
And so if everything comes from opinion
and just people developing their own ideas
is it just doesn't seem reliable to me.
- I feel like the only way
we can get unbiased news
is in order for news media organizations
to stop prioritizing, having
really vivid headlines
that might not necessarily
be 100% accurate.
I think that starts with
putting people over profit.
They want the biggest story or whatever,
and they don't wanna
actually give the news
that would be by beneficial
to our everyday average Americans.
And I think that if we
put a lot more focus
on putting people first,
instead of the big news
or the big story, we can
change that aspect of society.
- I agree with you 100%.
Like I say the civil rights movement
is the civil rights
entertainment industry,
'cause it's so profitable.
Put a police shooting on
TV it's breaking news.
Every headlines on every social media,
you selling shirt, you selling signs.
That's so much more
profitable than showing me
you shaking hands.
The news media is
literally capitalizing off
the emotions of society.
No matter how you feel about it
handling in your privacy of your house.
Why, because if you can do it on camera,
somebody's gonna make a dollar off of it.
And that's not fair to you.
- [Interviewer] Young people
today are too sensitive.
- So I think it's a good thing
that young people are sensitive.
I think today they can be more sensitive
than what they probably could
have been 30 or 40 years ago.
The growing up was the Berlin crisis,
the Cuban missile crisis.
I mean we had the threat of annihilation
staring at us several times.
And a lot of times I go, thank
God John Kennedy handled it.
- The country has been
spoiled for so long.
They're trying to make it
so a man can't be a man.
And if you don't let men be men,
then things start crumbling.
Society crumbles, families crumble
and broken homes start happening.
- And kids need they fathers.
So 36% of kids don't have a father.
So every boy is, well,
my mom is mad at me.
My dad don't love me.
My dad don't care about
me, maybe I should be gay.
Maybe I should be trans,
I don't know who I am.
And your father puts confidence in you.
No disrespect anybody.
But the younger generation
of men are soft.
And if we had to go to war,
they not protecting America.
There's no better place to
be as a black individual
or whatever you are in America.
Go to the Middle East right now
and say you gay or you trans
and see how they treat you.
I'm Johnnie 32 years old and
I am a conservative parent.
My grandfather was a no excuse individual.
He grew up in the Jim Crow
South, but he worked hard.
The house that he bought is
still in our family today.
He had a guard in his backyard
as you step past a certain
line he got on you.
So to watch the men before me
who really could have been lynched
for stepping outta of line,
who really could have
went through a hardship
for not doing what society said.
The worst thing that could happen to me
is I get a mean tweet or dislike.
So I gotta fully embrace who I am.
And I know I can create anything
with my two hands and feet.
- I'm Hannah, I'm 17 and I'm a liberal,
I really want equality for all.
And the liberal policies
that have been passed
side more with my values of equality,
for those who are on the LGBTQ,
those who are on the gender spectrum,
something about conservative
parents that I don't like is
whenever I come across them,
they seem to be very rooted in their ways
and not willing to listen
to someone who's a teenager like me.
They think more like, oh, 'cause I'm older
I have more knowledge,
which is not necessarily always the case.
- [Interviewer] Can we have
the disagreers step forward?
- This idea that because men
are being raised by women,
that they're weaker is in my
opinion, completely false.
Our generation it's not more
sensitive we're more aware
of all these things.
Being transgender and gay is not something
that is, should be ashamed of
or make you feel less in today's society.
That is why women are
fighting for equality
'cause this idea of that
because they only have a mom
they're weaker or because
they're more sensitive.
That's in my opinion, completely falls.
- And I would say in the
environment that I grew up in
the teen pregnancies come
from girls without fathers,
the homicides come from
people without fathers.
Every girl that I know if
they grow up with a daddy,
they get married before they have a kid.
- Why do they not have fathers?
- If you want me to be real
because a lot of women make bad choices
on the men they procreate.
If you make a bad choice,
that's your responsibility.
Every bad thing that I did in my life,
it was when my daddy was in jail.
When my dad was out and I
had my dad's reassurance,
I was a better person.
- I had one daughter that had
to move across the country
to get rid of a toxic relationship
with somebody that was harming them.
- Why does the woman have
to move across the country
because the man is being toxic?
Why can't the man be
taught don't be toxic?
- Oh, I agree.
- Women nowadays have to deal
with those kinds of relationships.
The women, the mother knows better.
I would say than the father about that.
- We're not more sensitive.
There's just more opportunities
for us to be sensitive.
You can say like 15, 20 years ago,
there weren't videos of black
men being shot by police
all over the internet.
Now that that's there,
people are more inclined to
feel a certain way or take
a stance on that topic.
- Do you think it would
be more beneficial to show
police also interacting with white guys?
'Cause more white guys get
kill than black guys by cops.
- If you look at the
amount of white people
and the amount of black people
there are gonna be more
white people killed
because there are more
white people in America.
The percentage of black
people that are being killed
is higher than the
percentage of white people.
- Well just because you're pulled over,
it doesn't mean you have to resist.
I mean, they don't just kill
you when they pull you over.
It's all about based on how
you perform as an individual,
I've been pulled over and
never had a bad interaction
in my life.
When I was rude, I got
snatched out the car.
Everything is a personal choice
and you can't take
accountability for your life
and you will forever be a slave.
- That's not true.
There are definitely issues
on the side of policing,
black communities,
majority black communities,
majority POC communities are over policed.
There's larger patrols
and black communities.
There are police where longer hours
in majority black communities.
So is an issue from the
policing side as well.
- [Interviewer] Politics
has damaged my relationship
with a loved one.
- I'm sure you could
relate to this as well,
but in the Asian community,
there's a lot of anti-blackness.
So with the advent of the
black lives matter movement,
this past year or having
conversations with my parents
was really difficult,
especially around the nuances
of racial justice and sort of like
what the movement was fighting for
and how to articulate that in
like the very closed mindset
that my parents had.
- A lot of my family voted for
Trump in the past election.
And I don't necessarily agree with that.
I don't like to say this,
but it may morals a little bit differently
and they're willing to adapt
and change was so different
and I was just like shocked,
'cause I wanted to understand their side
and really talk about it,
and I was met with you're wrong
and we don't wanna talk about it.
And that kind of really damaged
just kind of the way I looked at them.
- Yeah, I definitely agree.
And I also think that it
just made me less willing
to expand the energy to have political
or like just like any
like hard conversations
with my parents or
anyone else in my family.
My name is Ritwik, I'm 18
years old and I'm a liberal.
I grew up in a low income
immigrant household.
And I think the systems
that are in place right now,
aren't sufficient enough
to support people,
Americans like myself or my family.
Because my parents were immigrants
I think they were liberal
on issues like immigration
and things that directly affected them.
I'd like to ask to the
conservative parents
why they don't necessarily listen
or adopt their own beliefs,
whether they're political or social
based on the conversations
they have with their children
and why they're so set in their ways.
- I read a lot of the tragic stories where
family members don't talk
to each other anymore.
Personally I think that's sad.
Do all my family members
vote the same, no.
Do we have a pretty good
idea of how family members
may have voted, yeah.
But we actually, we want
more of agree to disagree.
I'm not gonna not buy you
a present for Christmas
because you decided to vote
for somebody that I don't like
give me a break.
Families are special and
we've got too many people
as you've talked about
that don't have them.
- When I took this prompt,
I kind of took it more of like
my view of the person changed
differently because not
'cause the way they voted,
but because some of their
value me were like you said,
moral values and that shows
kind of part of their characters.
- Would you say that
morality and subjective
to each individual person though?
Or would you say morals are
the same across the board?
- The basic is human equality for all.
And so if you don't believe
that somebody should have
inequality based on their gender,
their sexual orientation
or their race or anything
like that that's a moral
problem in my eyes.
- Because that's a huge thing
with the trans and the gay
and LGBTQ and all that whole thing.
So I grew up LDS being Utah county,
it's like 95% mormon at eight years old
is when you get baptized.
And so if you're raised
around where 95% of people
think the exact same way,
I feel like that's too young of an age
where you're a child and
you don't really know
what you're doing.
And so where I have a problem with
the trans or these different things
is they're getting kids
at like 10, 12 years old
and they're pushing them down that path.
- Who's they.
- Who's, they?
- Who's pushing, who's
indoctrinating these kids
into becoming LGBTQ and et cetera?
- There's a lot of groups out there.
Like I've just heard that
there's groups out there.
I don't know, you don't think
there's groups out there
that do that?
- No.
- I'm squeer straight man.
So I think it's weird for you to comment
on the squeer experience
and what that's like
for someone growing up,
who's struggling with those experiences.
The way you're describing
it as indoctrination
people who are figuring
out their sexualities
and their queer identities
aren't necessarily gonna
ascribe to the first labels
that are put before them.
- If I'm not mistaken, the
brain isn't fully developed
until you're 25 years old correct?
- Yeah, correct.
- I know how I used to think at 16 man.
I know how I used to think at 21, man.
I'm not against kids
doing whatever they want.
It's just the older you get you change.
I got my first tattoo at 15.
I'm covered now, if I was a little older,
I probably would've waited when
you young, you not thinking,
and everybody has made a bad choice.
And because you stressed out,
you go change your gender
because you want to try something new.
Once you do it, you can't go back.
The more you throw stuff at
kids before they developed
that's indoctrination,
because you're trying to get them
while they're not fully cognitive
to know what's going on.
- [Interviewer] The older you get,
the more conservative you become.
- When I got older and I
had kids and I had a family,
I actually start reading policies.
Everything about me changed
when I became a father.
'Cause I had a reason to,
and I'm sure you would agree with that.
- Yeah, as I've gotten older
and the environment we're
in right now I feel like
they're trying to cancel the constitution.
They're trying to cancel Christianity.
- I mean, most teenagers are liberal.
I was liberal when I was teen.
It's fun, Culture is liberal.
So hey, when you're younger,
you're gonna be a part of culture.
When you're older, you're
trying to raise your family.
You don't have a time to care about
will LeBron James said or who did that.
Just when you mature, you
value what's around you.
- My name's Sean,
I'm 36 years old and I'm
a conservative parent.
My dad's kind of my idol.
I've seen him basically
build a very successful life
and seeing how simple he's
lived his life through prayer
and through just basic
conservative principles
being raised up LDS or Mormon,
I saw a lot of just judgment.
And so I don't necessarily believe that
you have to be in a religion,
but I do believe in prayer,
I've been all across the board
as far as the way my life has gone.
And at my happiest times, I've
lived by conservative values.
- Building off what you're
saying about like teenagers.
We're a different generation.
And so we view the world differently.
And I think that's
probably why you've seen
more teenagers be liberal,
'cause we just view the world that way.
But I don't think it has
anything to do with--
- No my generation I was liberal
too when I was a teenager
and all my friends were too.
And when you're a teenager, life is fun.
It's just totally you
kicking you party you.
So that's what I'm saying.
I get the teenage as you grow
you either can run away
from responsibility
or embrace responsibility.
When there's real things going on.
You start looking at
life a little different.
Versus when I was young,
I didn't know about that.
I didn't know about corporate gangs tax
and I didn't know about my stock account.
And I didn't know that
I can all these things
that I didn't know when I was a kid.
- So when people are
generally talking about taxing
the richmore, they're talking
about the top 400 billionaires
that are literally paying
a lower effective tax rate
in taxes than the middle class.
The top foreign billionaires
paying an effective tax rate
of 8% that's obviously not a fair share.
And I think obviously
everyone can agree here
that they should be paying
at least a fair share, right?
- How do you re increase taxes
on someone's assets though?
That's most of those billionaires aren't.
- Unrealized capital gains
is how they're specifically
trying to do it now,
but it would be through
long term capital gains.
'Cause a lot of the people
who are paying those taxes,
they're paying capital gains tax rate.
There's also tax loopholes
that have been lobbied
into Congress by big corporations
and big businesses are being politicians
to get whatever they want through.
- So, if you get older
and you work yourself off
and you become a multi-millionaire,
you deserve to pay more
because other people
didn't work as hard as you.
- Yes, but it's not because other people
didn't work as hard as me it's because we,
as a society want to give everyone access
to things like basic necessities
like healthcare, education,
have everyone have an equal opportunity.
We don't have that right now.
- You can have equal
opportunity of a baseline,
but the outcome would still be different
'cause every individual's
gonna work different levels
obviously, right?
So I think that's where we are society.
I was able to pull it off.
I graduated high school with a 1.9 GPA.
I don't have a college degree.
So the only limits are the
limits you place on yourself.
That's just my perspective.
- [Interviewer] America is
the best country in the world.
- I think despite all of
our challenges and problems.
When you look at all the
other countries of the world,
everybody is still trying to come here.
- The way I can talk out loud,
the way I can feel myself,
the way I can express myself
fully as an individual,
it ain't many places
black men can go do that
outside of America.
- Three years ago when I
got into the court systems
and the different rights
taken away from me
and government control
and government power.
And so when you have that
stuff stripped away from you
and you realize most other countries
don't have the freedom that America has.
America has been the
greatest country ever.
And I think it will continue
because of a lot of good
people that stand up for
the right things.
- I think I would like
to ask the question,
what is America the best at?
- I think we just was
talking about the freedoms
that we have here versus what they don't
have in other countries.
- So what about places in Scandinavia
that actually have higher
amounts of freedom?
They have better
democracies than we do here.
Higher quality of life,
higher meeting income.
They have healthcare systems
that are more efficient
that take care of everyone
in their population,
more access to education.
- But when you look at the big a picture,
everybody wants to come here.
Millions of people are not
trying to get into Scandinavia.
- Why?
- Because we have more opportunity
than any other place in the world.
- We don't even make the
top 25 in women equality.
- But we have a better opportunity
to do something about it
compared to other countries.
And I would love it for Europe
to open their borders
the way we have and see
if you can get people from
other parts of the world
to do mass migration to Europe.
- I was gonna mention
Scandian countries as well.
But I think it's also
important to address that
Scandian countries are
very like homogenous,
like racially socioeconomically.
They don't face the same,
geographic diversity that we have.
We were mentioning with the fact that
we have the opportunity to write
what like women inequality,
like why is that not happening?
It's because the way
our democracy is set up,
our Congress is literally
in a gridlock right now,
as it has been for so many
past sessions of Congress,
we aren't getting
anything productive, done.
- The opportunity we
have here is incredible.
And I'm very happy that I live
here and not somewhere else,
but we are so focused on,
oh, America is the best
that we don't look at these
other countries and say,
why are all those people so happy?
And what is that?
And how can we incorporate
that into our society?
- I mean, I would say like
I think diversity is good.
I think diversity of
thought diversity of pain
of it's super helpful.
It's really easy to get clogged
up into this group think.
So I don't expect anyone
else to agree with me
or feel the way I feel.
I just expect you to respect
my right to feel this way.
I respect your rights, feel
this way and we keep it moving.
- 100% Agree, I couldn't
agree more actually.
- [Interviewer] Awesome, that's a wrap.
(both clapping)
(ethereal music)